hey guys Pete here this is going to be
my twin peaks' season 3 episode 12 recap
and review spent a long time in the
making but I do need to give you a
spoiler warning that if you haven't
watched part 12 yet then you're going to
want to click away so part 12 of the
return has turned out to be a polarizing
point in the season for people again
this is not the first time we've been
here but I was a fan of the episode on
the first watch and I liked it a lot
better as I continued to watch it and I
think there's some really interesting
stuff at play here the one thing I want
to point out before I jump into things
is that if you're one of the people who
was really angry about this and there
were several people who commented in
that way I think it's important to keep
in mind here that this is not a
situation in my opinion where time could
be wasted this is a story that's always
had a beginning and an end and after
they wrote that story they decided that
it would take 18 hours to tell it and as
the season goes on I think it's been
made abundantly clear that this is a
collaboration between two people this is
not a David Lynch production this is a
Mark frost and David Lynch production
and I think this episode is a perfect
example of that so I'm going to jump
into a bit of a scene-by-scene not quite
like before and then we'll talk about
that more at the end it's all right in
the first scene we get Gordon Albert and
Tammy all together in the hotel in
Buckhorn we learned some really
important stuff about the mythology when
Albert explains what the Blue Rose task
force actually is this is huge this is
something that we've all been waiting
for and it's something that is hinted at
in the secret history as far as dougie
Milford and major breaks are concerned
but this is actually the first time we
really understand where Gordon
involvement in all of this is so we find
out that back in 1970 after the air
force shut Project Blue Book down Blue
Book is a real thing and it was there
official 20-year investigation into UFOs
and the paranormal it was officially
shut down and according to Albert the
military and FBI formed a secret task
force to explore the troubling cases
that Luba couldn't resolve or failed to
resolve now in the secret history we get
dougie Milford who set up listening post
alpha where major Briggs works but we
never see the direct involvement of the
FBI other than he mentions that Cole was
the one person in government that he
could trust we also get a huge reveal
that people were wondering about based
on other theories and things where he
mentions that agent Desmond Chet Desmond
from fire walk with me was officially
one of the blue roze Ruth we also found
out that the term blue rose came from a
phrase that was uttered by a woman
involved in one of these cases just
before she passed away so that's
interesting
either way though we find out that
Gordon set it up he met he put his old
buddy Phillip Jeffries from Quantico in
as the leader
Chet Desmond Albert and Dale Cooper were
the original guys and Albert points out
that he's the only one that's still
around who didn't disappear mysteriously
then he says because of that fact that
they don't really bring anybody into it
for quite a while but that's until
tonight when he actually tells Tammy
that she can join if she wants and we
found out that they've been watching
Tammy for a long time that she was the
star student through high school college
and at Quantico she agrees to join
enthusiastically and then Albert says
that they will brief her fully in the
morning which again is a pretty big
thing what are we going to find out when
they briefed her if we see it I hope we
do but we'll see then they call Diane
and after they have a drink and her
entrance is bizarre there's been a lot
of different theories have been tossed
out of there just because of the fact
that she comes through a red curtain to
enter the room but when I watch it again
there's definitely something odd about
her behavior here
so anyways they tell her that they're
thinking about the fact that she could
be useful since she had really close
contact with Cooper and even though
she's not a member of the FBI anymore
they'd like to bring her on as a debt
you know deputize her as part of the
group then as the firewalk was me music
kicks in she says let's rock with a hand
gesture both things totally not like her
and I noticed him it stands out to me
that she puts her cigarette out before
she responds which she's always smoking
otherwise so yeah it's weird then we get
a quick shot of Jerry running out of the
woods he seems to be in a meadow below
the peak there and that's all we see
he's running he falls he has a giant hip
sack on and a backpack and that's about
all we can ascertain from that little
thing then we finally see Sarah come
back in the story Sarah Palmer and we
witnessed a freak out that is up there
with all the weirdness of the original
series and fire walk with me I would say
like this is a direct connection to all
that stuff particularly the horror
aspects of this show that we've all
loved for all this time not to mention
it's wonderfully acted I mean it's just
great but anyways she comes down the
aisle we finally see that shot that we
had seen in the trailers she's buying
liquor Smirnoff basically all they have
on the Shelf was some mixers and then
she becomes affected when she sees that
there's a new rack of beef jerky on the
wall behind the register it's almost
like she starts to lose control
the one thing she says is she asked if
it's smoked and then she says were you
here when it first came or when they
first came and you can see here that
there's a disparity between what she's
saying and the counter person's ability
to understand what's going on
she says the room seemed different and
men are coming she starts to really lose
it and she says you have to watch out
things can happen something happened to
me
so then leaves the store she's talking
under her breath it's almost like she's
talking to herself or to another boy
inside her head and we really can't say
for sure what's happening here now
there's been a lot of different theories
that people come up with but it seems to
me like there's something otherworldly
happening here that we can't see as
viewers make a quick trip over to the
fact route we get to see the good side
of Karl he has a quick conversation with
the guy an older gentleman who's been
doing work around the place and doesn't
really get paid for it he's found out
that this guy's been selling blood in
order to get money so he gives him some
cash and tells him he doesn't have to
pay his rent and it's a cool little
scene then we get our only interaction
with dougie coupe who we see sonny jim
take him outside but the baseball glove
and he tries to initiate a game of catch
and the ball just bounces right off of
doug too so i think a lot of people
probably would cite this as one of the
big disappointments because obviously at
the end of the last episode a lot of
people thought that he was coming back
in the scene where he was eating cherry
pie but he looks to be his old self here
and we don't get anything else so this
is what we're at after that we see Hawk
pull up at the Palmer House we hear the
old music playing and we get another
great performance and some uniquely
weird Twin Peaks stuff like we see that
the ceiling fans going that sets the
tone Sara is she being herself I don't
know I mean she seems to be really odd
here right he says hey I'm just here to
check up because I was going through
some old cases she sees through that and
says you're here because of what
happened and then we hear the noise it's
a mysterious unexplainable noise it
happens in the kitchen we can hear some
bottles or something I read some
theories about this that maybe the bag
boy who delivered the liquors over there
we don't really know this is at the
exact same time though and if we go that
road then we have to think that she is
actually possessed by the large spirits
or something along that line so for the
time being I'm going with it's a
mysterious unexplainable noise and
hopefully we find out more about
after that talk ask her she's okay and
if she needs anything and so on and she
says with her teeth clamped through her
clamped teeth she says it's a goddamn
bad story isn't it hawk and again we
don't really know what she's talking
about obviously her life is a bad story
what happened to her daughter what
happened to her husband
that's a terrible story but is that what
she's talking about we really don't know
we see that Miriam's okay but not much
more we do hear the monitors making some
noises as it cuts away but I'm not sure
that that implies anything and either
way we find out later that she's already
spilled the beans about Richard Horne to
the sheriff either way we see Diane
Macedo text message at the hotel bar it
says Las Vegas with a question mark and
she responds they haven't asked yet from
there we go straight over to the Great
Northern we see Ben in his office Frank
Truman comes in he tells them what I
just mentioned that Richard was the one
who killed the boy in the hit-and-run
that he also tried to kill Miriam who's
in the hospital now and she's in bad
shape and she needs some money because
she doesn't have insurance
Ben says of course of course I'll take
care of that he tells them that Richard
horns on the run and we don't really
exactly know what that means we saw him
last when he robbed his grandmother we
get a nice reference to Harry Harry has
Truman the old press share of Truman I
guess in this case but Frank only says
he's hanging in there which is what
we've already known as well the key
comes up he gives it to Frank to pass on
to Harry this sets off some alarm bells
and Frank's look about why it showed up
just now so there may be some further
investigation related to that happening
after Frank leaves that really comes
over and Ben tells her that Richard
never had a father and he goes into the
story about his own father and the
Schwinn bike with fat tires and I
mentioned in my top moments video that I
thought this kind of rarely put things
on Audrey as being Richards mother but
that was a very popular idea a lot of
people pointed out that Johnny would
still be like if you had
as a father a biological father that
would still be the same as not having a
father I would mention that it didn't
seem like that was his father whenever
he came over to rob the grandmother but
then again Richard is obviously being
painted as a sociopath so I don't know
that we can tell anything by watching
them let me get into Gordon's date which
I detailed quite a bit in the top
moments video so I won't retell it all
there's a popular theory out there that
somehow this is code that's going on
between them I really don't see it I
think this relates back to what I was
saying before but I won't get too deeply
into it basically this woman that's
there for Albert shows up we see that
she is completely leaning on Gordon's
shoulder just hanging off his every word
then when when Albert says he has
something important to them to talk
about can she wait downstairs she takes
what is the absolute longest imaginable
time to leave the room while Gordon
looks on lovingly as she does Albert is
everyone in the scene as he sits there
it has this crazy look on his face and
then Gordon tells the bad joke and
eventually they get down to business
of what Diane's text said Albert at one
point asked him about the wine and
Gordon makes it out like he thought he
said what time and he looks at the his
watch I don't know if he misunderstood
him there not a lot of people think he
didn't but it could just have been a
plot device to say what time it is
but at the end there's this really kind
of touching moment that he says
sometimes I really worry about you and
it's kind of like that team that we saw
way back with the blue you know when
they first come out of the prison after
seeing evil coot for the first time I
just think it's a real nice testament to
these actors and the relationship that
we all have with the series and it's
just freaking sad when you think about
it that miguel ferrer died and i mean
he's never even probably probably don't
even got a chance to see the scene play
out and I don't know it was a for me it
was so scene that brought up a lot of
sentimentality we can't focus on that
for too long though because we catch up
with touch and Chantal they have a brief
to
gushing about whether Chantal sure that
she's hungry that she or that she really
doesn't want to go out there and torture
this guy more than Murphy and it's a
great team in Soul areas they talked
about Wendy's and her being hungry and
then like a professional assassin he
kills warden Murphy with no problems his
son comes out to see his father which is
awful and they take off with him saying
next stop Wendy's like it was just any
other job we get a little transition
with doctor amp and at the time I was
just sort of like okay whatever but it's
starting to make me think about where
Jacobi fits into the puzzle at this
point we know that whenever he starts
off he says he's at whitetail Peak which
is obviously the opposite peak of the
Twin Peaks so that's interesting I
really don't know why Nadine is so
mesmerized by this guy but we don't get
a whole lot of new information here so
I'm just going to go ahead and skip it
beyond that so then we get the big
reveal and I think this is probably
where a lot of other feelings come up
for people because of the fact that this
is not how they expected Audrey to
return or how they expected her to be I
read a lot of people saying that maybe
it was acting maybe that maybe she was
playing a part in something and you know
I don't know but the information we have
in front of us is that this is her life
this is how things ended up her husband
Charlie is a guy that you've probably
seen in other stuff before he's a bit of
a character actor he does a fantastic
job here
like if you watch this over and over
like he is insanely good at playing this
part it's really cool she is a little
erratic and over-the-top but you kind of
get the idea that that child life would
be if you were trying to get your point
across to this guy like he is a stone
wall for the most part but anyways yeah
that's where she that we found out a
couple of things beyond the fact that
this marriage does not make sense on on
the surface I mean we found out she's
not married to John justice wheeler
that's for sure as she's not the
mysterion
billionaire in New York so she's
actually married to this guy who is a
paper pusher
it's a loveless marriage she's having an
affair with someone named Billy who is
also been missing for the past two days
and she wants to go out and look for I
think the general consensus is this
Billy is the man that we saw Andy talked
to back when they located the truck that
was used in the hit-and-run based on
Charlie talking to these other people
who may or may not be important Tina and
they mentioned Chuck there's all these
names all these new characters all this
new mystery but bottom line Audrey's
lover is probably dead she had a dream
that she saw him with blood coming out
of his nose and his mouth and it may
have just been a premonition of what
actually happened to him at the hand of
her relative Richard Horne I mean that's
my takeaway from it I'm not getting too
much into these other details because
I'm not really sure that they're
important I mean I got flames way back
in episode 3 because I said that I did
think some characters are important but
let's look at the facts there is a
definite campaign going on between mark
Frost and David Lynch to produce some
things that aren't important in this
theory it does a great job of adding to
the overall mystery and gives us
something to do so the same with the
Roadhouse scene at the end are those
people important I don't really know it
seems late in the game to bring them up
there's been other characters like them
that we haven't seen again so we're just
going to have to wait and see but at the
end of what we know is important we see
Diane punching the coordinates that she
memorized and we see the town of Twin
Peaks come up on the map and we know
that it's on the radar then like I said
we go into the Roadhouse people have
said that the chromatics are playing
again and they're wearing the same
clothes and maybe that is a clue that
the Roadhouse scenes might not always be
on the same timeline and there's
definitely you can go back and watch and
you can make your own decision on that
what I want to talk about is what I
started talking about and I think it I
think it's important to remember that
this is a series that was written and
they know where they're going like it's
it's it's kind of a waste of energy to
try to worry that somehow one individual
episode might derail the whole thing
Marc Krauss especially understands how
to write episodic television that's what
his background was and he was very
successful at it with Hill Street Blues
so you can say that there are ideas they
had them all together and then a
structure was laid out based on those
ideas so I think that everything is
going to be fine like I said I enjoyed
the episodes I didn't have any problems
there but I think it's a way of telling
us also that same thing that we hear at
the beginning of the secret history the
mystery is what's good not necessarily
the answers now like I said there are a
ton of theories going around about
different parts of this and some of them
are pretty good most of them involve
possession and Diane and Sarah Palmer
and they're laid out in pretty good ways
I don't really know I know I think we're
heading into the back stretch which
means answers to the key questions are
going to start to pop up but I don't
really expect that all of its going to
make sense I think the experience will
be good and I'm enjoying it so I hope
everybody tells me what they think
because there's you know I said there
was a lot of different questions and
people saying you know how are they
going to wrap it up I mean I think it's
just as likely that an event happens
that annihilate Twin Peaks removes it
from the map and everybody involved with
the story except for Gordon and Tammy
maybe survived that's equally as likely
as all these different threads get put
together but regardless and I mean look
I've make these videos I like to look at
every single thing I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with that at all
like that is fun but as long as the end
is satisfying it won't really matter if
we figure all this stuff out or not well
yeah let's enjoy the ride please like
this video if you enjoyed it make sure
to subscribe to my channel if you
haven't done so yet and
make sure you hit the little Bell
underneath to get notifications because
I'm putting out a lot of videos and you
want to make sure you don't miss a twin
peaks' one in that mix follow me over on
twitter and my other social media
accounts thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon